an evil Robot Babysitter a 75-foot shark
and one of Spider-Man's biggest enemies
these are the Sci-Fi films you don't
want to miss in 2023
one of the most anticipated movies of
2023 has got to be Dune part 2. the
follow-up sequel to 2021's massive
adaptation of Frank Herbert's science
fiction magnum opus both Dune and dune
part 2 come to us from critically
acclaimed director Denise Villeneuve the
man who's no stranger to sci-fi having
created incredible films like arrival
and Blade Runner 2049 Dune is the story
of a royal family in the distant future
that is exiled to the remote desert
planet of arrakis which is home to
everything from the enigmatic native
fremen giant hostile sand worms and a
precious Interstellar resource called
spice because of the massive nature of
the story from the original book bilniv
decided to break his film into two parts
to do these characters Justice Dune part
2 will continue where the last film left
off as audiences will follow Paul
Atreides and chani as they lead a
revolution of the fremin against the
planetary occupation of the evil house
harkonen the lead role of Paul atrates
is played by Timothy chalamet the
supporting cast of top tier acting
Talent including Zendaya Rebecca
Ferguson Stellan Skarsgard Josh Brolin
Dave Batista and Oscar Isaac in the
first installment alone in the upcoming
sequel the cast has gained even more
star power joining the cast are Florence
Pugh Leia sedu Christopher Walken and
Austin Butler Hot off his performance as
Elvis Presley in Elvis
following in the footsteps of sci-fi
horror movies about artificial
intelligence such as ex machina and the
Terminator comes Gerard John Stone's
Megan the story follows the creation of
a seemingly perfect robotic doll that is
supposed to serve as an ideal friend for
kids and even a possible babysitter for
parents but soon the evil Android begins
to take on a mind of its own the most
obvious comparison for Megan is to the
other iconic horror franchise featuring
an evil Toy Child's Play There's even
been some online beef between the
Twitter accounts for both Chucky and
Megan to hilarious effect you should
probably run Megan is the brainchild of
akayla Cooper and James Juan the latter
of which has become well known for his
work on franchise Fair such as Saul The
Conjuring Fast and Furious and Aquaman
since it's produced by blumhouse the
production company which is backed every
Jordan peel film to date this movie
brings back Allison Williams one of the
leads of get out it also features the
talent of violet McGraw Ronnie Chang
Ryan Jordan Alvarez Janet Davis and Amy
Donald as the main characters of this
horror flick since its January release
Megan garnered a lot of attention with a
viral dance scene and a staggering 30
million dollar opening weekend at the
box office you won't want to miss this
strong start to 2023's sci-fi roster
off the heels of their recent holiday
special it's almost time to check back
in with everyone's favorite team of
multi-species interstellar heroes in
this year's Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. with James Gunn back at the Helm of
the series he created back in 2014
Marvel has allowed the Guardians to have
one last hurray with the finale to their
Trilogy part 3 of the series brings back
all the main stars from previous
appearances including Chris Pratt as
Star-Lord Zoe Saldana es Gamora Vin
Diesel as Groot Dave Batista as Drax
Bradley Cooper as Rocket Karen Gillen as
nebula and many more taking place in the
far reaches of space within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 continues where the past
two films left off following the ongoing
story of this unlikely superhero team it
also requires some knowledge of movies
outside the series to fully understand
what's going on since these characters
were deeply affected by the events of
both Avengers Infinity War Avengers end
game and Thor love and thunder for
example the original Gamora was killed
by her adoptive father Thanos during the
infinity war and was later replaced by
an early version of the character from a
different timeline since Star-Lord and
Gamora were developing a pretty serious
romance this new Dynamic will surely
play a part in the next installment it's
also important to know how much drama
there was behind the scenes regarding
James Gunn since he was fired and
subsequently rehired throughout
production Autobots
that's probably what at least one giant
shape-shifting robot will say in the
next edition of the massive Transformers
franchise It Seems Like Only Yesterday
that audiences were watching Shia
LaBeouf stumble around big CGI robots
back in Michael Bay's 2007 Transformers
adaptation now there are six Mainline
movies and one bumblebee spin-off for
fans to enjoy Paramount pitchers is
continuing the story with 2023's
Transformers rise of the beasts which
will function as a sequel to bumblebee
since it takes place sometime in the
1990s with all new characters who have
never been seen before
Transformers rise of the beasts is
directed by Stephen kappel Jr it stars
Anthony Ramos Dominique Fishback Luna
Lauren Velez and Toby weegway as the
human characters who discover the
Transformer robots on an archaeological
excavation this film also features a
star-studded voice cast for the various
Transformers both good and evil the list
includes Peter Cullen as Optimus Prime
Pete Davidson as Mirage Sebastian
maniscalo as wheel Jack Ron Perlman as
Optimus primal and Michelle yo as
airraiser Transformers rise of the
beasts is directly inspired by the Beast
Wars era of the original toy line and
tie-in animated show which establishes
the existence of robots that transform
themselves into the image of animals
rather than cars we said goodbye to the
story of Katniss Everdeen and her
climactic struggle against the
oppressive government of the capital
although there was a satisfying end to
the series for many fans it should come
as no surprise that producers at
Lionsgate wanted to bring the franchise
back to life with some kind of prequel
these movies did make huge amounts of
money at the box office after all well
that's exactly what's happening with
2023's The Hunger Games The Ballad of
songbirds and snakes this film is a
prequel directed by Francis Lawrence and
based on a 2020 novel by original author
Suzanne Collins it takes place nearly 64
years before the events of the original
The Hunger Games Film by focusing on the
early years of The Hunger Games event
Tom Blyth stars in the leading role of
Cory Elena snow other talented
performers to appear in this prequel are
Rachel zegler as Lucy gray Baird Jason
Schwartzman as lucretius flickerman
Peter Dinklage as casca highbottom Viola
Davis as Dr valam Nia Gaul and Hunter
Schaefer as Tigress snow
every camera watching
another year another highly anticipated
Pixar movie The Legendary computer
animation studio is back at it in 2023
with a movie that's been shrouded in
more mystery than their usual projects
but Elemental got audiences excited for
what's to come through a recent trailer
that revealed some information it's no
secret that Pixar loves taking abstract
ideas or concepts and anthropomorphizing
them they did this with emotions in
inside out and souls and souls so it
seems as though Elemental is continuing
that Trend by portraying various natural
elements as people Elemental takes place
in element City a metropolis where all
the elements of the world live together
in harmony as conscious beings it will
feature groups of little Elementals
based on fire water and land as they
interact in an urban environment it
sounds similar to Disney's 2016 film
zootopia but with elements instead of
animals the story itself will focus on
two elements a fire woman named Ember
and a water man named Wade as they
become unlikely friends despite their
natural differences it's official
synopsis from Pixar itself goes into
more detail about its on-screen Dynamic
the description explains the story
introduces Ember a tough quick-witted
and fiery young woman whose friendship
with the fun sappy go with the flow guy
named Wade challenges her beliefs about
the world they live in Elemental is
directed by Peter sun and stars the
voice acting Talent of amaru ache and
Leah Lewis as Wade and Ember
respectively
as if the mag wasn't big enough it's
going to get even bigger with Meg 2 the
trench this sequel follows up on 2018's
over-the-top Sci-Fi Action story about a
75-foot ancient Megalodon hunting a
group of scientists out in the Pacific
Ocean the sequel continues the story of
rescue diver Jonas Taylor as he must
once again deal with this pesky
Megalodon at even lower depths than
before while there's little information
out there about the plot of Meg II the
trench it's safe to assume that the plot
involves both another Megalodon and
possibly even a trench the Meg was a
surprise box office hit back in 2018
making over 500 million dollars
worldwide off a budget of only 130
million dollars despite a generally
negative critical reception the first
film only managed to snag a 46 score on
Rotten Tomatoes from critics and an even
lower 42 score from audiences and yet
somehow it did well enough to Warrant a
sequel regarding the choice to make
another the Meg Jason Statham himself
explained the reasoning during an
interview you with Entertainment Weekly
during the first movies press tour
saying I think it's like anything else
in this day and age if it makes money
there's obviously an appetite to make
more money and if it doesn't do well
they'll soon sweep it under the carpet
but that's the way Hollywood works
yet another superhero movie on this list
is DC's upcoming Blue Beetle movie which
will bring the iconic techie character
to the big screen for the first time for
those who don't know a lot about the
character here's a quick crash course on
everything you'll need to know Blue
Beetle is a superhero whose real name is
Jaime Reyes who gains power after a blue
alien Scarab attaches itself to his
spine because of this event he can form
a protective exoskeleton around his body
at will which easily allows him to fight
crime basically he's DC's answer to
Spider-Man hi do we do I know you
Blue Beetle will be directed by on Hell
Manuel Soto and features a mainly Latino
cast the actors include sholo maridwenya
Bruno marchesini George Lopez Melissa
Escobedo Adriana Barraza and Damian
Alcazar to name a few in fact this is
the first film within the DC extended
Universe to have a Latino lead character
at all which is a big milestone for the
franchise in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter cholo maridwenya
discussed how essential the Latino
background of the character and his
family was to the history of Blue Beetle
saying with this character he lives with
his family and there's no way to hide
who he is right from the very first
moment he gets his powers his family
knows that's different
would it surprise you to learn that even
more superhero movies are coming out in
2023 of course not there are so many of
them that it would be bizarre if there
weren't at least four per year to watch
that being said the upcoming Craven the
hunter adaptation differs in many ways
from the other sci-fi superhero flicks
on this list Craven the hunter directed
by JC shander is a collaboration between
Columbia pitchers Sony and Marvel to
continue Sony's separate Cinematic
Universe of movies like The Amazing
Spider-Man Venom and morbius it will
star Aaron Taylor Johnson as The Larger
than Life character of Craven the hunter
a dastardly Big Game Hunter who has
often been a dangerous enemy for
Spider-Man throughout the comics during
an interview with comicbook.com Johnson
went into detail about what kind of man
Craven will be in his solo film
explaining this is a character that was
built ages ago and it's in a new time
and era but yeah is he going to be the
hunter that we all want to see yeah
absolutely
[Music]